what did you learn of big Pharma that
maybe the rest of the world who's not in
the business won't know meaning it gets
a lot of criticism a ton of criticism
right from uh uh today I think pink did
a uh ad on her Instagram profile and she
the shadow was towards Pfizer today and
what she did do she got a big uh
pushback from a lot of different people
because she turned off it's the second
one click on the second one right there
I think that's the one and at the top if
you click on that picture
what does it say at the top I don't know
what you're doing Rob does it just go
away
just read the top right read the top
right
top right it says paid sponsorship no
click on it again and you'll see top
right it says paid sponsorship Pfizer
you won't be able to see it but if you
do it on your Instagram that's what it
shows okay anyways she turned off the
comments
and everybody starts posting it saying
why did you turn off the comments
because she never turns off the comments
because most people went after Pfizer
right hey you you you're taking the
money you're doing this you're doing
that from a guy that's in that space
how dirty is that world
I think it's the dirtiness that bothers
me less about it yeah I could point I I
think the dirtiness on Wall Street
exceeds the dirtiness come on factor in
Pharma yeah I think so I would say so
yeah I mean in what way I'm curious I
live in the hedge fund I mean I think I
think the raw game playing the raw type
of of sort of quasi-fraud behavior right
saying one thing and doing another
the the motivations of most people who
work in the industry I think that's
actually the biggest actually it took me
a while to get to that's the biggest
difference I think most people who work
in the Pharma industry
genuinely in some way wanted to work on
medicines that make people's lives
better I think most people who work on
financial institutions in Wall Street
wanted to turn a pile of green pieces of
paper into a bigger pile of green pieces
of paper there's nothing wrong with that
motivation but it turns out when things
go wrong in the managerial class then
runs the show in both institutions the
latter of them leads I think to you know
in more fraudulent or quasially
fraudulent directions the problem in
farm is my biggest problem with it is
different
it is built in the shadow of the FDA
okay literally you asked me for
something that most people who aren't in
the industry wouldn't know
I think the org structure like the
organizational structure of most
companies yep is literally built on
modeling itself after the agency that
regulates it okay and the FDA doesn't
just decide which drugs to approve
that's a common misconception
the FDA dis governance and its decisions
govern every little teeny tiny step you
take along the way of drug development
you have to ask Daddy for permission to
you know lift lift the hand
to take it to your mouth before you
swallow before you swallow the food and
then after you swallow it and then to
take another bite that's the level of
permissioning required and so this
entire industry has built itself like
one of the arms of the administrative
State and it mostly operates kind of
like the administrative State it's a
bunch of managerial bureaucrats that run
the show they're very consensus driven
which is to say that they engage in
group think all the time if Trends shift
in One Direction you're not going to see
somebody step out to be a contrarian why
because just like the government most
big Pharma companies if you take a risk
and you succeed like let's say you're
the guy who
developed Lipitor and advocated for
putting money into it before it became a
mega Blockbuster you're not seeing any
of that personal uncapped upside on the
other hand if you're that person who
made that decision and it fails you
might lose your job or have your budget
cut so people have no incentive to
actually step outside of the mold to
challenge conventional Dogma succeed
they're regulated by a government
massive Byzantine bureaucracy that
literally even the titles in the org
chart are modeled directly after their
corresponding titles at the FDA that it
more operates almost like a wing of the
government than it does like most
segments of the private sector then you
get the patent system that creates this
Monopoly profit that once you get to the
other side of the line once you get to
the promised land
the Monopoly profits actually disguise
the effects of normally what you'd get
in consumer products markets something
like this through competition that has
more that disciplining effect on our
organization it further ossifies that
bureaucracy so my main critique of big
Pharma is that it operates as the
embodiment of the managerial class in
the private sector and you know it's a
long story for another day but that's
what actually created the opportunity
for me to found royvent to develop drugs
that Pharma had neglected or passed over
but to do it in a way that you know
often even bought up some of their own
projects off their own shelves and
developed them and you know five of them
are FDA approved products for medicines
today so if you like this clip and you
want to watch another one click right
here and if you want to watch the entire
podcast click right here
foreign
[Music]